boris johnson the home secretary
announced that afghan citizen
resettlement scheme before this debate
the big question though
is it enough does the uk need to do more
to really do its bit in this crisis
well the almost certain answer to that
is no we need to we will need to do more
i mean the
canadians have already committed to i
think 25 000
taking 25 000 afghans pretty much
straight away i mean not spread over
four years uh the truth is we actually
don't know how many there will be
seeking uh safety um we have to look at
everybody who's worked for us whether as
a contractor or directly obviously we've
already made um progress on the question
of the interpreters but but others as
well uh we'll also have to look at
people who are going to be politically
oppressed for one reason or another and
maybe uh women i mean the the speaker
you had the parliamentary speak you had
up just now
uh talking very eloquently about that
and we simply don't know how many will
get out either bear in mind uh if
they're not allowed out by plane by the
afghan authorities so by the taliban
then getting out across land is not
going to be easy either because they've
got
pakistan
iran and a number of countries that are
not going to be very helpful
so
we are having to make decisions i think
pretty fast pretty much on the hoof but
what i think we can guarantee is that
5001 years not going anywhere near
enough
you say these decisions are being made
on the hoof and that's what's
frustrating for people watching at home
and that frustration has been uh
expressed in the debate today that these
plans are being made after the event we
have known for months that the us is
withdrawing troops that nato troops will
follow that the uk will have
no troop present in presence in
afghanistan people could see this coming
perhaps not at such speed
but regardless of the speed you know it
happened a plan wasn't in place and
that's another big question that surely
has to be answered by the prime minister
the foreign secretary and the home
secretary the plans just weren't there
well i think two things i mean firstly
there was some of it foreseen because
when i raised myself back in june the
whole question of afghan interpreters
and actually to be fair to the
government i'm not i said sometimes i'm
happy to be critical when i need to be
but to be fair to the government between
me asking my question on on the order
paper and between the home secretary
answering it they made a policy a policy
of of actively trying to help
people to be interpreters for our armed
forces and so on what they that issue
has been around for years yeah yeah but
nevertheless you know when i pressed
they moved um and that was a few months
ago but the problem yeah and part of the
problem is that nobody forcible i think
even the most pessimistic and i'm
probably amongst those nobody foresaw
the sheer speed of collapse of the
afghan government if somebody come on
your program a month ago and say and
said in a month's time the taliban will
be in charge
you would have heard them i mean most
people have thought they were wrong
that's what's happened a large part the
responsibility for that i'm afraid is
down to the two consecutive american
presidents the way they handle it but
nevertheless we can't do anything about
that now the issue now is to get on top
of it i agree it would be better if we'd
had more advanced plans laid
but remember in the middle of the copic
crisis as well other things distracting
people
it would have been better now we have to
move fast what that says i can move fast
if canada can move fast if the americans
say they can take thirty thousand now
they're gonna they're gonna need to take
at least three times that amount by the
way but if they can say that now if
the canadians can move then we're gonna
have to move a bit faster than five
thousand money here
can we just talk about a time scale um
reference has been made to the syrian
refugee resettlement scheme where the uk
promised to take 20 000 refugees over
five years what kind of time scale are
we looking at for the refugees of
afghanistan because for them time is of
the essence the taliban have been in
control of the country officially
probably since sunday
we've seen the absolute chaos
around the kabul airport of people
trying to get out they are frightened of
the taliban they will say they haven't
got
five years they fear that the taliban
will be searching for them and hunting
them down within the coming weeks and
months
i agree
and i think
to compare it with
the syrian scheme is just
irrelevant frankly
the people are going to come we're going
to come in five minutes not not five
years um and our problem
is going to be how we cope
with the at the new afghan authorities
um uh whilst we're trying to extract
people from their grip
and that's not going to be easy it's not
going to be easy but we've got to do it
you know and it won't show up in some
business school textbook we have to use
our brain and do it for ourselves
so what's that going to look like
because the practicalities of this
situation are very difficult here on the
programme yesterday afternoon i spoke to
a gentleman called pen farthing um a
former serving soldier in afghanistan
who now runs an ngo in the country an
animal charity and he spoke to us on the
phone and he said
at the time he couldn't find his wife
and a heavily pregnant colleague who had
gone to the airport who couldn't even
get into the airport even though the
advice from the british government when
they made contact with the embassy was
to get to the airport to get one of
those evacuation flights they couldn't
even get into the airport so there's
a practical element at the moment that
the government need to sort out and does
that involve more troops going what does
that look like because that's going to
have to be the first step surely it may
well do and i understand that um
an aircraft british aircraft left this
morning with almost no peak money
because they couldn't get them through
the bearings now
that's good that's going to take uh some
pretty heavy duty administration too so
it may well mean more troops go out it
also may mean some pretty robust
conversations with the new afghan
government uh and we're going to have to
do that
and put some fine ways of putting
pressure on
we're going to have to talk to our
allies this is this is a very very
difficult task we've got to do
but it either happens now or it doesn't
happen but if we're still predicting
about it in six months time we probably
failed
and you know they're going to be they're
going to be people who work for us
directly uh obviously translators but
other people do drivers and other people
they're going to be indirect people
people work and contract as far as uh
they're going to be people who feel at
risk for it because of politics they're
going to be women who worked
in the open as it were and are now being
sent home there'll be a
a potentially vast number of people and
we have to uh get across those practical
issues we also need to to talk to our
allies very carefully to make sure that
that
those who are not under pressure can
help us out and there may be some so so
it's not an easy task i agree with you
it would have been ideal if we planned
it all out last year but you would have
had to have a degree of prescience in
the middle of a covert crisis uh to do
that and get the resources right our
government no government in the world
really had that presence
uh we've now got to move very fast to
make up for it uh otherwise the next
time we have a foreign policy excursion
of any sort um people are going to be
very very thoughtful indeed before they
actually help uh our armed forces and so
it's not just in their interest it's not
just a matter of
of
i was going to say christian charity
probably the wrong phrase but but
charity it's a matter of actually doing
our duty to the people who helped